I'll give you an example how tall was
your last boyfriend
um six one okay what percent of men do
you think are six one
maybe like
it's nice thirty percent
ten percent
so you had a top did how much money did
he make well he had he had his own
houses and the business he sells cars
okay so roughly how much do you think he
made
good I didn't I she don't know that yeah
I'm one too mine ain't telling you that
yeah but he owned it I know about his
business and you know I don't know
figures in London in Essex or in Essex
yeah okay so if he owned a house he
probably made at least like 60 70 I
guess who knows he had a nice range okay
so he's he's probably like I'm guessing
right I don't actually know you guys
would know London prices more than me
but he's probably still top 20 of income
probably because buying a house in Essex
is cheap yeah okay so top 20 so you had
a guy top 10 high top 20 income was he
attractive was he good looking yeah he
was yeah so in women so you know women
we find 80 of men is ugly so if you find
him attractive that means he's top 20
right you shouldn't me call him is he
still singing no he's been trying to
holler at me to be honest I don't have
to block him
no no it's not I'm very smart trust me
like he was wearing a mask when we first
met and then his true colors came out
and I saw it in certain behaviors that
he was portraying what true colors so
like you know he was very aggressive
sometimes and he I felt like his mom
what do you mean aggressive did he hit
you
no no he didn't hit me no okay so he
didn't well he pushed me he shoved me
very hard and it was for a very pathetic
reason and he's alive do you shove him
at all no just once no I don't like to
be aggressive I don't believe in that
no more I've grown up you know okay
so he he shoved you one time yeah and it
was very and it was petty and he lied at
the time as well and I knew he was lying
about picking up his kids when he wasn't
he he changed his story like I'm very
observant he's like picking up his kids
so I spent a couple days with him and he
and I was supposed to say the last day
and he and then he all of a sudden he's
got to go and pick up his kids but
you're lying and so it's like you're
making me feel like you don't want to
see me you don't want to you don't want
me to stay anymore so and then that
happened then we broke up and now he
wants me back
I know he wasn't because his story
changed he told me something we planned
something from the get-go so I know so
so yeah you don't have no physical
evidence of that I do I do I do it's
very it's very technical but it's like
you think I'm crazy if I go into it
right now shoving happen like what what
led up to that because he wanted him to
leave okay so literally
because I knew he was lying like come on
I don't okay okay
so why do why do a lot of women like
they accuse a man of being like the bad
guy the guy that hurts them the guy that
beats them but then the reason they like
they made they caused the reason because
if you physically don't move in certain
spaces
it's the way you speak to someone it's
the way you conduct yourself in that
situation but if you're in this has
happened to me before I've been Esther
you know you know
um no there's a girl here and I asked
her to leave and she didn't like the way
I asked her to leave right and then she
starts yelling at me
um and then
um well we didn't have security then but
my security would have just picked her
up and taken her 100. but then it's like
the way you're saying this it's like
what are the other options
see the thing I would have done that but
when it's an emotional sexual connection
you've got other feelings like you feel
rejection you feel like you're being
violated it's just stupid but it's kind
of different you're coming so you're
kind of making yourself so basically
like you were kind of overbearing
because he you thought he did something
and you had no proof he did it no I did
because he said what he changed his
story but you've never said two things
that contradicted yourself ever I I have
it just happens when you talk
it's very easy to to say the wrong thing
if you're being cross-examined because
you know what when you say earlier on
where my not analyzing women and women
are analyzing man he's looking at you
like raw so you're gonna argue against
me picking up my kids
no matter whether you know it's not all
it is yeah in his head right hold on I'm
telling you something about my kids and
you're arguing against my kids
to him
right to privacy
maybe there is something that he just
didn't want you to know maybe he was
Private with the mud like you know I
mean like baby mama situations can be
tricky like sometimes guys don't want to
get you in on all the drama but it's
like you're going into it in bad face so
you're assuming the worst when maybe it
wasn't the worst but I also feel like
it's just the way you conduct yourself
in a sensitive situation as well it's
like I just feel like couldn't we say
that to you though because it's the way
like you didn't listen when he said
leave so it's kind of like as women like
we kind of have this double standard
where we make him the bad guy when it's
like you kind of started it but then oh
yeah I remember now that also the reason
was like I've stayed in the house by
myself before and at this point he like
he didn't want me to stay so it's like
if you love me why can't I stay here
while you go and pick up your child do
what you need to do and I'll stay here
tonight and you come back because he's
because that's entitled
this apartment if I if I want anyone to
leave at any time I have the right to do
that like that wasn't the issue I
honestly I didn't have an issue with
that it was just the way it happened and
the things that he was saying and the
way he was speaking to me it was kind of
like but this is like a lot of problems
with women in relationships we want men
to emote like women but he's not a woman
he's a man men don't speak like women do
like they're much more Stern and so a
lot of times like we think something's
aggressive but men are just more
aggressive than women you might want to
call them but we're not aggressive he
seems like a hard man to replace can we
just say it again and you said in the
beginning that the men that like you you
don't want so that means then you want
don't want you wow I haven't met the one
I think no but that's like that's what
any girl that's single it just means the
men you want don't want you and it's not
meant to be the thing is it's actually
crazy because there's no one I actually
want
apart from there's okay but okay come on
there's nobody in the world that you
would want I'm attracted to like someone
but he's but he's like a celebrity
figure you're like sex appeal but
there's no one actually you think okay
do you think you're on like the level of
a celebrity yeah
you're pretty I think I'm an amazing
person
celebrities like top 10 20 of beauty
like that yeah but remember I think I'm
beautiful I think I'm beautiful without
the botox without without the money
without all that money to do myself up
so I think I'm great this is like a cope
I see women do like it's like you you
think because they have money they're be
they're beautiful when they got there
money helped but if you look at Margot
Robbie before fame that girl was a 10.
but then you're doing selectiveness
because there's enough girl that go with
it and the money blows them up only
I disagree not the girls that get there
for looks alone top 20 of beauty you can
look at exceptions like that like Kylie
Jenner she's not she's not beautiful she
wasn't beautiful before no she was cute
but yeah I mean she wasn't that
beautiful
but but like I'm just saying in general
guys like can we just talk in general
instead of exceptions most celebrities
are top 20 of Beauty in general
and like we could talk about there's
some exceptions like Kylie Jenner did
her lips whatever but most most people
in Hollywood were the top 20 of beauty
wherever they're from
I still didn't agree but yeah okay I
feel you I don't know maybe you should
call him no definitely not he might oh
I'm an apology I don't know no I have we
had a closure but he's not the one for
me he's not the definition of the one
I just feel like there's a different
there's a difference in Behavior and the
way you feel as well I can I'm not a
possessive person I can accept I really
like my Independence but I just know
there's a certain way that you will
handle someone in those situations
sorry I just know within myself sorry
your only child no I've got brother and
sister the youngest I'm in the middle oh
okay you know so girl it's fine so
growing up did you did your mom have a
partner do you have a stepdad no no yeah
yeah like no but not permanently so what
in terms of looking at do you know how
to look after a man because you're
saying certain things that in a
relationship it's like
if you saw a relationship with your mom
or dad growing up then there's certain
things you wouldn't do in a relationship
to God I'm saying to keep the man
listen every man every every man that's
been my boyfriend has returned and they
haven't found better yeah
you've been proposed to win again not
like on on one mean I haven't had that
experience yet but I've had similar I
bought you around yes I've had similar
but not like that we was young so
promising basically kind of like okay
okay it is what it's the same thing it's
rare for some amount to do that promise
rings don't captain no it does because
it's rare because it does not do you
think that men get go out and buy
promise rings
[Music]
but you have to really like you to be
because he's not going to do that to
everyone no no I'm not gonna lie okay
it's never gonna happen it doesn't count
you need a wedding date yeah a wedding
date not not a little ring but I was
young anyway no okay so it wasn't a real
it wasn't a real proposal no no no no no
okay so so the whole point is like
you're counting things that don't count
it doesn't count if they don't want to
marry not for you well they do their
intention is no like men say things when
they mean it they do it
um like you can't you can't count it
like I know what you mean but you know
happens you know I've had guys say
I want to marry you it doesn't count
unless he goes by the Rings this is 100
we can't like like I don't know why I
was count things that don't count you
know it don't count it so Paul you've
been proposed to a couple times or no no
I don't care like
so no one's brought a ring and said no
no no it don't count like it's like I've
had a promise ring there's a promise
ring a wedding ring no no it's not I
don't count that by the time we feel
like did he say it was a promise ring or
did he say it's an engagement ring no he
said it was a promise ring and then he
said he was trying to he he said it
doesn't count that's what I'm saying
actually he was trying to get the the
property
it it doesn't count as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick-Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible